STEVE WELCOME BACK TO "FOX &
FRIENDS."
DEMOCRAT MAY WANT TO PUMP THE
BREAKS ON VEHICLE MANDATE AS
TOYOTA'S PHASE OUT GAS CARS AND
GO EXCLUSIVELY ELECTRIC IS THE
RIGHT IDEA.
>> Rachel: IS HE WARNING, QUOTE,
PEOPLE INVOLVED IN THE AUTO
INDUSTRY ARE LARGELY A SILENT
MAJORITY THAT SILENT MAJORITY IS
WONDERING WHETHER E
INVESTMENTs ARE REALLY OKAY TO
HAVE EVERY SINGLE OPTION.
BUT THEY THINK IT'S THE TREND SO
THEY CAN'T SPEAK OUT LOUDLY
BECAUSE THE RIGHT ANSWER IS
STILL UNCLEAR.
>> Brian: WAIT UNTIL THEY.
>> Rachel: THAT'S OKAY.
YOU ARE INTERPRETING THE QUOTE.
>> Brian: WAIT UNTIL THEY DECIDE
YOU CAN'T CHARGE.
>> Rachel: IT'S ABOUT CONTROL.
GO AHEAD, BRIAN.
>> Brian: I WILL TAKE IT FROM
HERE, RACHEL.
A FORMER ARKANSAS GOVERNOR MIKE
HUCKABEE JOINS US NOW.
GOVERNOR, THE TOYOTA IS NOT
MARCHING TO THE BEAT THAT
SUPPOSED TO.
>> YEAH.
THERE'S A REASON THAT I DRIVE
TOYOTA AND LEXUS VEHICLES
BECAUSE THEIR PRESIDENT ACTUALLY
HAS SOME COMMON SENSE.
HE UNDERSTANDS THAT THE
MARKETPLACE IS NOT READY TO GO
EXCLUSIVELY TO ELECTRIC
VEHICLES.
WE JUST DON'T HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND IN ORDER TO GET THE
ELECTRICITY, TO MAKE THOSE CARS
RUN, WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO USE
THE VERY FUEL, THE FOSSIL FUEL
THAT INBE ENVIRONMENTALISTS
THINK IS SO EVIL.
SO IT MAKES NO SENSE.
THIS IS A POLITICAL AGENDA.
THIS IS NOT AN AGENDA ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT OR ABOUT THE
ECONOMY.
THIS IS AN AGENDA OF PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO SEE SOMETHING HAPPEN.
THEY DON'T CARE HOW IT HAPPENS.
THEY DON'T CARE WHAT IT
DISRUPTS.
BUT THEY ARE GOING TO PUSH FOR
IT.
I JUST THOUGHT BRAVO TO THE
PRESIDENT OF TOYOTA FOR SPEAKING
SOME SENSE INTO THE ISSUE.
>> Steve: YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE
THINGS, GOVERNOR, IS THE FACT
THAT THE DEMOCRATS FAMOUSLY
PUSHED DURING THE, I BELIEVE,
ONE OF THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE
THINGS THAT YOU COULD GET A
SUBSIDY, A TAX SUBSIDY UP TO
7500 BUCKS.
YOU READ THE FINE PRINT.
THE CAR HAS GOT TO BE BUILT IN
AMERICA OF ALL-AMERICAN PARTS.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE WHAT THAT
CAR LOOKS LIKE BECAUSE THERE ARE
NOT THAT MANY WHETHER IT COMES
TO ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
>> WELL, STEVE, YOU REMEMBER THE
FLINTSTONES CAR THEY RAN IT WITH
THEIR FEET?
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE HEADED IF
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE GOING TO DO.
FRED AND BARNEY DRIVE THESE CARS
PARTS COME FROM ALL OVER THE
WORLD NO.
SUCH THING AS A CAR THAT IS SO
TOTALLY MADE IN AMERICA.
BE NICE IF IT WAS.
BUT, THAT'S NOT WHERE WE ARE.
>> Rachel: GOVERNOR IT ALSO
MEANS WE ARE GOING TO BE
DEPENDENT SOME OTHER COUNTRIES
FOR INPUT TO THIS ELECTRIC
VEHICLE INCLUDING WE JUST SAW WE
DID A REPORT YESTERDAY ON THIS
SHOW ABOUT THE DEAL THAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS MAKING
WITH REPUBLIC OF CONGO TO GET
MINERS THAT WE KNOW ARE MINED
WITH CHILD LABOR.
WITH CHILD SLAVE LABOR IN
AFRICA.
I MEAN, THIS IS INHUMANE.
THIS IS A HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSE.
AND WE COULD PRODUCE THESE
MINERALS IF WE WANTED HERE.
ONE QUICK THING HERE, GOVERNOR
HUCKABEE, I KNOW YOU ARE SAYING
HE IS TALKING COMMON SENSE.
BUT HE IS ALSO THE PRESIDENT OF
TOYOTA SAYING THERE'S A SILENT
MAJORITY.
IS HE LITERALLY ADMITTING THAT
PEOPLE WITHIN THE INDUSTRY ARE
AFRAID TO GO AGAINST THIS
REGIME, THE BIDEN REGIME AND
TALK ABOUT FOSSIL FUEL MOTOR
CARS.
>> AND I DO THINK THAT'S ONE OF
THE SIGNIFICANT THINGS THAT HE
MENTIONED IS THAT THE
MARKETPLACE OUGHT TO BE DRIVING
THIS.
>> Rachel: RIGHT.
IT.
>> NOT ENVIRONMENTALISTS.
LET'S HOPE THE REST OF THE
INDUSTRY WAKES UP AND GETS THE
MESSAGE.
>> Steve: ALL RIGHT, GOVERNOR.
THANK YOU JOINING FIVE DAYS FROM
CHRISTMAS.
ME